أعطِ الرئيس بايدن أول مائة يوم على الإطلاق ،
آه ، كيف حاله ، سأمنحه
درجة وأنا طالب صعب ، سأمنحه
كليهما في
مجهوده لأنه قام ببعض الأشياء
بشكل جيد للغاية.
مرة أخرى يجسد ونمذجة ما
يجب على الرئيس أن يتصرف به في المكتب البيضاوي
بالبيت الأبيض في العالم بأسره
أه بكرامة وهادف
أه مع الحرص على ما
يقوله وكيف يعامل الناس أم
واهتمامه بالتفاصيل و  الفريق
الذي أحاط نفسه به ممن
يتمتعون
بالخبرة في كيفية جعل عمل الحكومة الفيدرالية
قد أنتج قدرًا هائلاً
من الإجراءات الإيجابية ليس فقط
للتراجع عن السنوات الأربع الماضية ولكن حقًا
البدء مرة أخرى لجعل الحكومة
تعمل بالطريقة الصحيحة
و  إذن ، فإن تمرير خطة الإنقاذ الأمريكية
لجلب الأموال إلى جيوب
الأمريكيين الذين ما زالوا
يعانون اقتصاديًا هو
الشيء الصحيح تمامًا الذي يجب
القيام به ، وقد تم إنجازه ، وكان متفرغًا
للأمر وأخيراً
رجل.  إن الحصول على 220 مليون طلقة في الأسلحة
لإيصال اللقاحات إلى هناك وإصلاح
سلسلة التوريد هذه
باستخدام الحكومة الفيدرالية من
خلال fema والحرس الوطني
ليكونوا جزءًا من الفريق ، وتظهر الولايات
والمحليات
فقط كيف تبدو الحكومة المختصة
وهذا هو سبب
حصوله على هذا  معدلات قبول عالية في
جميع المجالات بالطبع لديه
درجات موافقة عالية من الديمقراطيين ولكن
حتى
بين المستقلين والجمهوريين ،
لا داعي للقلق طوال الوقت
الذي لا يضطرون فيه إلى حبس أنفاسهم
عندما يرون رئيسهم على
شاشة التلفزيون.  لا داعي لك أن
تعرف أن تهز رؤوسهم وتتساءل
أنك تعلم أن الرئيس
سيقول لهم أن يشربوا مادة التبييض ، أعني أن
لدينا الآن رئيسًا ناضجًا من ذوي الخبرة
والحمد لله أننا نفعل